[Music]
amok today news probably said at the
same time not today Satan submitted by
earnestly yours
Toronto oh I think jewelry store workers
fought off intruders with swords in a
midday robbery attempt I love these kind
of videos that's [ __ ] tight I'm just
saying I'd like to watch videos when I
stop Tyson there's a video you never
seen these you know when storekeepers
fight back it's one of the best things
ever I like it yes the only time I've
seen it is whenever we talk about it
here usually it's with like a shotgun
I'm always like oh this isn't as fun to
watch no there's this couple that
spanked a robber Oh any [ __ ] yeah the
preacher it was like a black eye and the
guy tried to come in rob him and he was
in his garage and he was like spanking
oh yeah well that's another one but this
was like a asian couple and then they
got the guy they pulled him over the
counter pulled down his pants and
started spanking him Wow and he was born
with a gun yeah and they'd had nothing
damn tell me the whole story and they
were 80 with ellipses in the middle one
was missing a leg
we're giving you the floor Joe so you
don't interrupt yeah I already told all
my information it loses the flavor if he
doesn't interrupt though yeah yeah give
him the end is yeah yeah I don't know
when you speak and it reminds me of
things if I go oh and one more thing
and you can't wait even like 30 seconds
you inspire him welcome thank you I'm
alright so these employees and a
Canadian jewelry store they were quick
to fight off these would-be robbers and
so I'm gonna show you the video I like
how they just have swords inside this
right like they can't get a gun so
they're just gonna leave stores in that
I mean that's very Canadian of them I
wish they actually stuck someone though
that would have been cool yeah the guy
just crawl right back over so they're
looking for men there were four men
involved and I wonder if they're real
swords like are they for the display or
their axle because it's really hard to
find a real sword or if they're like
sharpened swords made tea for use yeah
oh man I wanted it like lie down with
the sword so as soon as they jump up you
go oh man you [ __ ] stabbed them
you're in a kid it doesn't pour out
immediately not in the kids movie
there's actually no blood in the kids
movie yeah because they're just trying
to hack away like that you need a stick
you don't do this you poke they're not
murder is psychopaths they were using
like a decorative swords bro because
they were just like trying to swat like
a [ __ ] rat that's how they were doing
it like true you just didn't want to
stick them no you gotta go in yeah but
then you gotta clean they did all this
[ __ ] and they got the guys to leave
without sticking them yeah I didn't have
to get before the guys come back again
but it's like they're going through the
window right and then you go in and then
they go out of the window like this so
then you just gotta clean that I take it
back I like how your scenario is so
perfect it is you just got to do it like
this yeah yeah even though these guys
already won yeah I don't know how they
might come back
that's like Conan oscar-winning director
it's like what you should have done in
the movie and he's like no cooking one
dude like they're not learning a lesson
that's what that's what I'm saying is
like you want to teach them a lesson at
least kill one of their buddies Wow
do they sell those things where it's
like a gun and you shoot and it's like a
net that comes out oh that's cool love
to have one of those because I wanna
catch them the police can take them to
jail yeah there's that large that's true
for Batman shoot for me and if you stick
one of them they have to go to the
hospital yeah or maybe they have a
first-aid kit at home maybe they have a
veterinarian dr. in some dark alleyways
for spring jazz watches movie one of
them dies then they can catch the other
three because they can ID the person no
they can if the one died no but they'll
know like who his friends are yeah
because they're gonna go to his funeral
like we have to go the funeral we have
to so what about the cops like we have
to go we have on their honorable
someone's going someone's going to the
funeral you never seen those mob movies
they end up all going and they all take
pictures cuz they can't reason it always
rolling through with the car window just
open they have honor and respect yeah
yeah we would see him lumbering slowly
out of the vehicle - I love all that
thought slow motion and I gotta look
cool - when I was in high school I had a
buddy who had like a weapon wall so we
got a [ __ ] axe and swords sounds like
Joe I used to have one
did you wall with weapon did you also
have a lure the rings ring around your
neck that you wore at school okay he
doesn't keep though from like a $200
gold ring or have the inscription on it
from the movie $200 terrible that means
you're a [ __ ] geek then if that was
your friend dude he was he was my most
embarrassing before okay bear see all by
for his girlfriend yeah you're a nice
guy I didn't disown him for it but I was
like damn dude you are this is rough you
had a wall of weapons oh that's all you
wanted to share yeah it's one of these
people with weapons at the bay ready to
go but he's also one of those people
who's like was a man on you know when
[ __ ] goes down and [ __ ] and you're like
I feel like this guy has a cool dad
that's always shirtless and has like a
like a pool table room with all these
naked girl calendars and you're like
what's going out and daddy goes no
that's going to my weapons
I wish man his dad was like just some
Mexican nerd
it worked at Qualcomm damnit sex welcome
you never heard of all gone
this is like a gigantic billion-dollar
company isn't that the cable company I
don't know
they didn't tell telecommunication so
yeah but isn't that a local local cable
network
Qualcomm yeah no it's like AB it's a
huge huge company you're making this up
you guys are so [ __ ] dumb sometimes
man I can't even believe it you did I
yes cuz when I get trolden I somehow you
all look dumb and that's me getting to
I'm right okay that's fine look this
[ __ ] up Qualcomm Stadium
om qu8 there's an L in there right qu al
cielo wasn't Qualcomm like it you
control real hard down like in the 90s
mall cop
no it's cool it wasn't it like bought
out or like murder you know what it is
deal tell us what it is no I'm just
laughing at him at what to an American
multinational semiconductor talk
communications equipment company boom
yeah there's two M's it's not like Honda
or Nike you don't I mean like you're
you're acting like it's like sure it's
like you don't know what don't get
donuts is like it's like but it is kind
of like this see you just proved to
everyone how much of a [ __ ] geek you
are I'm fine with that
that's like you're Lisa bit I guess big
[ __ ] just doing Janeiro general things
[Laughter]
man
[ __ ] Texas I never [ __ ] used
Qualcomm yes sir I wasn't gonna reveal
that part yet cuz I wanted you guys to
feel extra dumb it's hard to make this
room that's why I thought it was a local
cable network I don't know if this room
can fill time it's not though they're
big it just sounds like a conglomerate
my god yeah it sounds like a Viacom like
one of those Congrats
it's gigantic conglomerate media come on
from this [ __ ] my point is that my
Mexican friends dad worked at walk on it
so I [ __ ] said everyone going
we're trying to get me all we're gonna
get seen you're gonna be mean to give
know there's a light jab I'll let you
troll so hard
nobody believes you anymore I think it's
called quality communication how about
that how about that well now you know
watching this video Qualcomm facts today
everybody I want to squiggly say hello
is this story about the squiggly sword
how do best I'm saying how did you get
from one of the most exciting things
I've ever heard
so [ __ ] librarian talk you made this
happen we might as well be talking about
California freeways you thought oh yeah
you take the 5 to the 134 yeah don't
ever get on the for 1000 to 10 East is a
goddamn that's the area code there's a
410 in San Antonio
you don't take the 405 down to Laguna
make sure you get off swear beefing I
want to live in the Luna anyway we're
talking about these swords here you're
so mean see I'm not me oh come on Tim
it's all love a good sense when Steve's
fallen or not and I knew it wasn't
rolling yeah I knew he wasn't rolling
either but then it became something
bigger than it was and I was just he can
never know it was funny that she had
said I'd never heard of it and so I was
like aw it's just to the UM billion
dollar corporation no I got your back
too
I don't know you there but look I just
this is that but everyone got
[Laughter]
[Music]